>> Laura: DEMOCRATS HAVE
LAUNCHED A BLITZ OF USING TRUMP
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION OF
SEPARATING CHILDREN FROM THEIR
PARENTS AND HOUSING THEM IN
LITERALLY CONCENTRATION CAMPS
ALONG THE BORDER.
LEFTIST POLITICIANS FROM
SENATORS TO HILLARY CLINTON TOOK
THEIR BEST SHOT.
>> IT IS UNACCEPTABLE IN MY
MIND.
I THINK IN THE MINDS AND HEARTS
OF MANY AMERICAN THAT SOMEONE
CAN JUSTIFY A POLICY OF
DELIBERATE HARM TO CHILDREN AS A
WAY TO GAIN LEGISLATIVE
LEVERAGE.
>> IN FACT WHAT HE'S DOING IS
HOLDING THESE KIDS AND THEIR
PARENTS HOSTAGE TO A WHOLE SET
OF OTHER IMMIGRATION ISSUES.
>> SEPARATING FAMILIES IS NOT
MANDATED BY LAW AT ALL.
THAT IS AN OUTRIGHT LIE.
AND IT'S INCUMBENT ON ALL OF US,
JOURNALISTS AND CITIZENS ALIKE,
TO COLLEGES THAT.
>> Laura:
>> Laura: OKAY.
WELL, SHE SHOULD KNOW SOMETHING
ABOUT LINE, RIGHT?
WITH EMOTIONS RUNNING THIS HIGH,
IS IT A P.R. BATTLE THE
ADMINISTRATION CAN WON.
LET'S DISCUSS ALL THIS WITH THE
HEAD OF THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
WE ARE PLEASED TO WELCOME
ATTORNEY GENERAL JEFF SESSIONS.
FIRST TIME ON "THE
INGRAHAM ANGLE."
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING WITH
US.
THERE'S A LOT TO GET TO TONIGHT.
YOU HEARD WHAT MRS. CLINTON
SAID, THAT THIS IS A LIE.
IT'S NOT CAUSED BY THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
THIS DOESN'T HAVE TO BE DONE.
THE PRESIDENT COULD PICK UP THE
PHONE TONIGHT AND STOP THIS
POLICY OF SEPARATING CHILDREN
FROM THEIR PARENTS.
WHAT'S THE REAL TRUTH THERE,
GENERAL SESSIONS?
>> I GUESS WHAT SHE IS SAYING IS
THE PRESIDENT COULD JUST ISSUE A
DIRECTIVE THAT EVERYBODY THAT
ENTERS THE COUNTRY UNLAWFULLY BE
RELEASED INTO THE COUNTRY AND
NEVER BE APPREHENDED OR STOPPED
OR PROSECUTED FOR THE ILLEGAL
ENTRY.
WE HAVE WATCHED WHAT HAPPENED
WITH THE OBAMA POLICIES, AND
OVER THE YEARS, WE WENT FROM
15,000 ILLEGAL ENTRIES TO
75,000.
THIS IS A HUGE LOOPHOLE IN OUR
SYSTEM THAT'S ATTRACTING MORE
AND MORE PEOPLE AS MORE AND MORE
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THAT UNDER
PREVIOUS POLICIES, IF THEY WERE
ENTERING THE COUNTRY UNLAWFULLY,
NOTHING EVER HAPPENED.
BUT WE ARE DOING THE RIGHT
THING.
WE ARE TAKING CARE OF THESE
CHILDREN.
THEY ARE NOT BEING ABUSED.
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES HOUSE
THEM IN GOOD CONDITIONS.
THEY WORK HARD AT IT.
WE SPENT A BILLION DOLLARS LAST
YEAR, HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
DID, IN TAKING CARE OF CHILDREN
WHO ENTERED THE COUNTRY
UNLAWFULLY.
LAURA, ONE MORE THING.
CHILDREN STILL TEND TO BE THE
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS.
WE HAVE HAD A BIG SURGE IN
FAMILIES BRINGING CHILDREN OR
SOME ADULTS BRINGING CHILDREN
WITH THEM.
>> Laura: ONE OF THE SHELTERS
NOT TOO FAR FROM THE BORDER HAS
90% OF THE KIDS WHO ARE
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS.
10% WERE SEPARATED FROM THEIR
FAMILIES.
JUST SO MY VIEWERS UNDERSTAND
THIS.
GENERAL SESSIONS.
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN A FAMILY UNIT,
YOU SEE THEM ALL ON THE BRIDGES,
WHICH I THINK IS ABSURD THAT
THEY STAY ON THE BRIDGES NEAR
THE PORTS OF ENTRY NURSE
SAN DIEGO.
NOW, WHEN THEY GET PROCESSED IN,
IT IS SLOW.
THEY GET PROCESSED IN AND IF A
WOMAN SAYS THIS IS MY CHILD OR
TWO CHILDREN, THEN WHAT HAPPENS?
ARE THEY SEPARATED IF THEY CLAIM
ASYLUM, SAYING I WANT TO CLAIM
ASYLUM?
WHAT HAPPENS TO THE MOTHER OF
THE CHILDREN AT THAT POINT?
>> IF THEY ENTER THE COUNTRY AT
A PORT OF ENTRY AND THERE ARE
MANY OF THOSE ALONG THE BORDER,
THEY ARE NOT VIOLATING THE LAW.
THE MOTHER OR FATHER IN THAT
CIRCUMSTANCE WOULD NOT BE
PROSECUTED IN THE FAMILIES ARE
STAYING TOGETHER.
PRESUMABLY THEY ARE CLAIMING
ASYLUM AND THEY WOULD NOT BE
PROSECUTED AND NOT BE SEPARATED.
BUT IF THEY GO OUT IN THE
DESERT, THEY CROSS A FENCE OR
BARRIER, OUR OFFICERS HAVE TO
IDENTIFY THEM.
FOLLOW THEM, APPREHEND THEM.
THEY ARE VIOLATING THE LAW AND
THE NEED TO BE PROSECUTED FOR
THAT.
HE SIMPLY CANNOT CONDONE THAT
KIND OF ACTIVITY.
WANT TO END THIS PROCESS OF
CHILDREN BEING BROUGHT ACROSS
DANGEROUS TERRITORY, PLACING
THOSE CHILDREN AT RISK.
IF THEY WANT TO CLAIM ASYLUM
FROM A LET THEM GO THROUGH THE
THAT'S THE WAY IT SHOULD BE
DONE.
>> Laura: YEAH, I THINK MOST
PEOPLE AREN'T UNDERSTANDING
THIS.
I THINK MOST PEOPLE THINK THAT
IF YOU COME, EVEN THROUGH ONE OF
THE 25 PORTS OF ENTRY, YOU CAN
HAVE YOUR FAMILY SEPARATED.
THAT'S NOT HOW IT'S WORKING.
IT'S A RARE CIRCUMSTANCE WHEN I
THINK THE BORDER PATROL PEOPLE
KNOW THAT THIS PERSON IS NOT
RELATED TO THIS OTHER PERSON
THEY CAN FIGURE IT OUT PRETTY
QUICKLY IN THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO HAVE
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THAT.
THIS IS HOW YOUR OPPONENT,
GENERAL SESSIONS, OUR DEMAGOGUE
BEING THIS ISSUE.
SIDING WHERE THE FAMILIES WERE
SEPARATED, AND THAT'S WHY USE
THAT PICTURE.
LOOK, I KNOW WE ARE NOT NAZI
GERMANY.
ALL RIGHT?
BUT THERE IS A COMMONALITY
THERE.
>> THIS IS THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
IT ISN'T NAZI GERMANY, AND
THAT'S A DIFFERENCE.
WE DON'T TAKE CHILDREN FROM
THEIR PARENTS.
UNTIL NOW.
>> Laura: NAZI GERMANY,
CONCENTRATION CAMPS, HUMAN
RIGHTS VIOLATIONS, LAURA BUSH
HAS WEIGHED IN.
MICHELLE OBAMA, ROSALYNN CARTER.
YOU HAVE ALL OF THE FIRST LADY'S
GOING BACK TO ELEANOR ROOSEVELT.
SHE HAS APPARENTLY WEIGHED IN AS
WELL.
GENERAL SESSIONS, WHAT'S GOING
ON HERE?
>> IT'S A REAL EXAGGERATION.
IN NAZI GERMANY, THEY WERE
KEEPING THE JEWS FROM LEAVING
THE COUNTRY BUT THIS IS A
SERIOUS MATTER.
WE NEED TO THINK IT THROUGH, THE
RATIONAL AND THOUGHTFUL ABOUT
IT.
WE WANT TO ALLOW ASYLUM FOR
PEOPLE WHO QUALIFY FOR IT.
PEOPLE WHO WANT ECONOMIC
MIGRATION FOR THEIR PERSONAL
FINANCIAL BENEFIT AND WHAT THEY
THINK IS THEIR FAMILIES BENEFIT
IS NOT A BASIS FOR A CLAIM OF
ASYLUM.
BUT THEY CAN MAKE THAT CLAIM.
WE WILL PROCESS IT.
AND I WILL REVIEW THE SITUATION
AND MAKE A DECISION.
THOSE CHILDREN, IF THE PARENT
BRINGS THEM ACROSS THE BORDER IN
AN UNLAWFUL AREA AND THE PARENT
IS DEPORTED, THEY WILL TAKE THE
CHILDREN HOME WITH THEM.
THAT IS TRUE.
IF THE PARENT CLAIMS ASYLUM AND
IS ALLOWED TO STAY HERE, THAN
THE CHILDREN STAY HERE ALSO.
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES TAKES
CUSTODY.
>> Laura: GENERAL SESSIONS, IS
THIS POLICY IN PART USED AS A
DETERRENT?
ARE YOU TRYING TO DETER PEOPLE
FROM BRINGING CHILDREN OR MINORS
ACROSS THIS DANGEROUS JOURNEY?
IS THAT PART OF WHAT THE
SEPARATION IS ABOUT?
SLICK OF FUNDAMENTALLY WE ARE
ENFORCING THE LAW.
IF YOU BREAK INTO THE COUNTRY --
>> Laura: IS IT A DETERRENT,
SIR?
ARE YOU CONSIDERING IT A
DETERRENT?
BECAUSE THE FACT THAT NO ONE WAS
BEING PROSECUTED FOR THIS AS A
FACTOR IN A FIVEFOLD
INCREASE IN FOUR YEARS IN THIS
KIND OF
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
SO YES HOPEFULLY PEOPLE GET THE
MESSAGE AND COME THROUGH THE
BORDER AT THE PORT OF ENTRY AND
NOT BREAK ACROSS THE BORDER
UNLAWFULLY.
>> Laura: LET ME GET YOUR
QUICK THOUGHTS, SIR, IF YOU
WOULD ON THIS LOOMING CHILD WITH
CONGRESSIONAL INVESTIGATORS.
THEY ARE TRYING TO GET THOSE
DOCUMENTS, AS YOU KNOW, FROM
YOUR DEPARTMENT AND TREY GOWDY
OVERSIGHT CHAIR SAID YESTERDAY
OFFICIALS WILL BE HELD IN
CONTEMPT OF CONGRESS OF THE DOJ
AND FBI DO NOT COMPLY WITH
SUBPOENAS.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT?
>> WELL, WE'VE GONE A LONG WAY
IN DEALING WITH THAT.
THE FBI'S WORKED HARD ON THAT I
THINK.
AN AGREEMENT WAS SIGNED WITH
MR. TREY GOWDY AND
MR. GOODLATTE.
STAFFERS AT THE DEPARTMENT OF OF
JUSTICE AND FBI LOOKING AT THE
RECORDS.
I THINK THAT'S MOVING ALONG
PRETTY WELL.
>> Laura: THEY ARE OUT OF
PATIENCE.
GENERALIZATIONS -- GENERAL
SESSIONS, I HATE TO INTERRUPT.
SOME OF THESE DOCUMENTS END UP
SHOWING UP IN THE IG REPORT
CONGRESS' FOR MONTHS AND MONTHS
AGO.
YOU WERE IN CONGRESS.
YOU KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE TO TRY
TO DO OVERSIGHT.
IT'S REALLY FRUSTRATING.
THEY ARE HOLD ROSENSTEIN IN
CONTEMPT.
THEN WHAT?
>> WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO
RESPOND TO CONGRESS.
WE INTEND TO BE RESPONSIVE TO
CONGRESS.
IF WE ARE RUNNING BEHIND IN
PRODUCTION, WILL TAKE EFFORTS TO
STEP IT UP.
WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO
PRODUCE THE DOCUMENTS THAT ARE
PROPERLY DISCLOSED BULL AND WE
INTEND TO DO SO.
THAT'S MY DIRECTION TO THE
DEPARTMENT.
>> SENATOR SESSIONS, ATTORNEY
GENERAL SESSIONS, ONE MORE
QUESTION.
ARE YOU INVOLVED AT ALL IN
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT A POSSIBLE
RECUSAL OF ROD ROSENSTEIN OF
MUELLER, GIVEN THE FACT THAT HE
SIGNED UP FISA WARRANT.
IT'S A BIG CONTROVERSY IN THIS
CASE.
>> I'M NOT INVOLVED IN THAT.
HE IS THE ACTING ATTORNEY
GENERAL FOR THAT MATTER, AND HE
HAS TO MAKE HIS OWN DECISION, AS
I HAD TO MAKE MY DECISION.